por una aplastante mayoría los chilenos
rechazaron el texto que durante un año
elaboró una convención constitucional
para reemplazar a la vigente desde la
dictadura de augusto pinochet esta
decisión de los chilenos y chilenas
exige a nuestras instituciones y actores
políticos que trabajemos con más empeño
con más diálogo con más respeto y cariño
hasta arribar a una propuesta que nos
interpreta a todos que de confianza que
nos una como país la vigente carta
magna- seguirá rigiendo aunque el
presidente de chile gabriel boric ya
anunció que convocará un nuevo proceso
constituyente y que se cumplirá con el
mandato del plebiscito de octubre de
2020 en el que casi el 80% de los
chilenos pidió un cambio constitucional
sin embargo este resultado muestra que
el apoyo de la población ha disminuido
debido a la preocupación por ciertas
propuestas ya las controversias que
involucran a los constituyentes elegidos
para redactarla algo que junto a la
crisis inflacionaria y de seguridad
supone un duro golpe para el gobierno de
bolt pues esta votación pese a que no se
trata de una elección a un cargo público
es vista como una evaluación de su
gestión
figuras políticas han afirmado que la
constitución actual debe ser enmendada
por el bien de chile algo con lo que
coinciden los ciudadanos bueno que salga
todo bien para chiles finalmente que una
chile todo este proceso el lunes los
líderes de todos los partidos políticos
se reunirán en el palacio de la moneda
para analizar los resultados del
plebiscito constitucional